In this recitation,
we're going to talk
about predictive
coding-- an emerging
use of text analytics in the
area of criminal justice.
We'll start with the story of
Enron, the United States energy
company based out of Houston,
Texas that was involved
in a number of electricity
production and distribution
markets.
In the early 2000s,
Enron was a hot company,
with the market capitalization
exceeding $60 billion,
and Forbes magazine ranked
it as the most innovative US
company six years in a row.
Now, all that changed
in 2001 with the news
of widespread accounting
fraud at the firm.
This massive fraud led to
Enron's bankruptcy, the largest
ever at the time, and led to
Enron's accounting firm, Arthur
Andersen, dissolving.
To this day, Enron
remains a symbol
of corporate greed
and corruption.
Now, what Enron's
collapse stemmed largely
from accounting
fraud, the firm also
faced sanctions
for its involvement
in the California
electricity crisis.
California is the most populous
state in the United States.
And in 2000 to 2001, it had
a number of power blackouts,
despite having sufficient
generating capacity.
It later surfaced that
Enron played a key role
in this energy crisis
by artificially reducing
power supply to
spike prices and then
making a profit from
this market instability.
The Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission, or FERC,
investigated Enron's
involvement in the crisis.
And this investigation
eventually
led to $1.52 billion settlement.
FERC's investigation
into Enron will
be the topic of
today's recitation.
Now, Enron was a huge company,
and its corporate servers
contained millions of emails
and other electronic files.
Sifting through these
documents to find
the ones relevant
to an investigation
is no simple task.
In law, this electronic
argument retrieval process
is called the
e-discovery problem,
and relevant files are
called responsive documents.
Traditionally, the e-discovery
problem has been solved
by using the key research--
in our case, perhaps,
searching for phrases
like "electricity bid"
or "energy schedule"--
followed by an expensive
and time-consuming
manual review process,
in which attorneys read
through thousands of documents
to determine which
ones are responsive.
However, predictive
coding is a new technique,
in which attorneys mainly
label some documents
and then use text
analytics models trained
on the manually
labeled documents
to predict which of
the remaining documents
are responsive.
Now, as part of
its investigation,
the FERC released hundreds
of thousands of emails
from top executives at Enron
creating the largest publicly
available set of emails today.
We will use this data set called
the Enron Corpus to perform
predictive coding
in this recitation.
Our data set contains
just two fields--
email, which is the text
of the email in question,
and responsive, which is
whether the email relates
to energy schedules or bids.
The labels for these
emails were made
by attorneys as part of the
2010 text retrieval conference
legal track, a predictive
coding competition.